ask me how I'm doing I mean just to say
brat hey hopefully you're doing better
than you look
I'm hurry up all night I I went to via
veneto again two nights in a row I get
sucked in because fab reaches like let's
eat a goddamn steak I'm gonna open a
bottle of wine I'm like well you know
everybody's asleep I'll just take a
little mosey over and just and get a
little up and then and the food is there
and then I'm like I'm eating this
knowing I'm not gonna sleep knowing I'm
gonna wake up in the middle of the night
like I'm in a sauna because I'm old so
you can't eat hay when you're 50 don't
eat cow and drink a gallon of red wine
Danaher so here's the other advice when
you're 50 don't hang out a restaurant
all the time at night well that would be
you're always hanging out with that that
would that maybe there's something in
that too maybe green maybe it's a little
strange but you know that's that's my
hangout I try to get Grillo out Grillo
is back in town Oh is he yeah but he was
just too tired yeah Frank is a maniac
yeah um ask me how I'm doing how do you
do best day yet brother best day yet
that's me again how you doing knocking
the [ __ ] cover off it brother who
says I can't stand what people who says
that it's a guy I know who's always like
that knocking the cover off and was
knocking the cover off it what does he
do yeah you want to know yeah I do
because they can works for Federal
Express these are wrong dude that's a
great job always super happy not gonna
cover off it it's so [ __ ] knocking the
cover off yeah not gonna cover off it
best day yet
all right there you take it easy right
now no I cover does he does he go back
home and jack off with his tears you
know most people like that usually it's
a cover-up yeah usually there's a show i
watch called money day fiancé
you know what that is no it's people in
the states who have fiance's that are
foreign so I have to come here they have
a 90 day visa to get boy yeah and
there's a girl on there from I think
it's you taller some and she's so where
I'm going she's so happy and just and
just has no idea about the real world it
almost pisses me off
well some people some some people are
super happy like so the already Lange
one time said to me I'll never forget
this we were like 28 and he said man he
was he was he's such a smart and genius
comic but he gets you know he's probably
there's some darkness there that you
think yeah he goes um he goes the best
way to go through life if I have
children I want them to be really dumb
and really good-looking so they don't
have any other state yeah so they're
just really they're really good-looking
so these come they get to get the girl
they don't they just they where they
look great when they look in the mirror
they just wake up and it's and and but
they're dumb as [ __ ] so they're not
aware they're not aware of there's
anything else out there they're just I
don't know if it's dumb but there are
some people who who are only seeing
what's in front of them that day and I
always have envied them because they
don't really even think about how
dangerous well you know they also the
ones that get robbed raped killed in
like and later they go over to some
foreign land they're like we're just
gonna hike and just walk around the
hills in Jamaican I don't get it they're
the one that run to the gunshots cuz
they think it's a parade yeah my buddy
my buddy who used to work at the Foreign
Service would always deal with this you
get Peace Corps volunteers and they'd be
like just a just a sweet human being
wanted to change the world they work for
the Peace Corps and sure enough they'd
be like listen you don't it's great that
you're mingling with the the local
population please understand that any
local population whether it's in Africa
whether it's Jamaica whether it might be
like every other human being and every
other population
you got you got criminals yeah and you
got criminals yes no even if you're
there for good yes criminals don't and
there was this couple and they were just
they were just super liberal and they
were so great and they were just like
and then they'd go up to the mountains
and they'd just travel and yeah they got
following up there well guys the guy
just held them at gunpoint and then tied
the guy up and you know molested didn't
rape but molested the girl robbed them
she's robbed them tied him up to rob
them and then he was like this girl's
hot you might have a cop a couple fields
and some other stuff and that's what he
did anyways you know they left and they
they left
but there's so many stories about this
where a guy gets once you get really
into the culture and this happens a lot
they don't talk about and he'll be in
like some Amazonian you go to some
Amazonian tribe or some African tribe
and drink the tea he'll just drink the
hallucinogenic tea with the shaman or
whatever he disappears into the forest
because he's hallucinating on some crazy
drug he decides I want his vision yeah
yeah right they got it they got I got
sent a dispatch team and there they find
him like emaciated covered in bugs hi
thawne's don't discriminate they don't
care if you're Aboriginal Diaz no give a
[ __ ] about that you're getting that's a
gun that you hate the [ __ ] reference
this lame show but it's on TLC that
90-day fiance this guy has a girl in
Brazil and she's like sleeping on dirt
floor like broke broke like crazy poor
he goes out there and the you know
there's its TLC so there's camera crew
and this is in the favelas of Brazil
well the Brazilian them you know they're
like camera crew what they probably have
cool electronic on camera and this is it
made of this is for reals they get they
get because they're on their cell phones
cuz don't he doesn't speak pork to
Portuguese Portuguese she does right
obviously so there's a language barrier
so they have to tax and it translate the
text so they can read back and forth
yeah well the poor kids in Brazil go
cell phones but those are worth
something
those cameras boom mics ever those are
worth something let's rob them with
machetes oh and they're literally guys
like oh and then you see like the camera
like on the ground and lit some light
like it's right what like this portion
of the program
you know we apologize if it you know
made anyone upset yeah robbed on camera
with machete
yeah they don't give up they don't watch
everyone you can tell they're like it's
like a super rough ear you can tell like
these kids like like people keep going
by looking at like what they get all
these lines and also the Gazelle trots
by like know the hyenas and there's
basically a plump cow American Calvin
like look at that and he's they're just
flaunting it they're having a good time
trying to figure out when she's gonna be
reality man kids like not like what's
going on here
man machetes and they could like give it
your fault until you have slice you she
just toss different reality a lot of
gang rape too for Peace Corps volunteers
really tough because a lot of women will
go into these places alone and they go
into you know whatever it might be and
they're always there's always a group of
[ __ ] bad dudes and they get they get
raped you know you're this young girl
naive you're trying to make a difference
in the world you're there to dig wells
or whatever problem is you're hanging
out at you know twelve they're a bunch
of thugs that are drunk bang bad news we
saw the story don't go to the Peace
Corps don't go to the Peace Corps and if
you do just make sure you know what
you're doing and respect the fact that
it's a different culture respecting
bacteria like anywhere else there are
good areas and there are bad areas there
are good people and there are bad people
but the craziest anywhere though but the
biggest mistake people make is the idea
that okay I come from American I might
be white I came from Denver where I mean
well I mean well of course I feel lucky
of my privilege I want to go make the
world a better place all awesome things
the mistake you make is when you go into
a poor area you think that there's a
nobility that comes within a purity that
comes with poverty that comes with
living sort of close to the ground and
all these things but the human beings
the human beings and some of them are
most of them are wonderful I know this
from my own personal experience and of
course there's always a criminal element
especially in the favelas especially in
the yeah what's thing we're doing with
lions like you know what you're doing
horse yeah he looks friendly it's all
good the lion man just cuz you play
rugby doesn't mean let's duel I mean
scratch his head for Velas do favela
[ __ ]
a hundred percent 100 percent and that's
why we your that's why we're gonna do
this show from the favela that's right
well you're not going to with those pink
shoes of course because those are those
are for the wrestling mat these are for
will have a ric flair shirt on sir well
you you're the only person I know only
because your cauliflower ears and your
background that can wear those now you'd
be surprised
kids these days rocking some paint man
I'd like to wear some pink I'm just a
little old to get to just roll around in
athletic shoes huh yeah
I'm just hopefully a tennis game I miss
out and I'm a sportsman isn't the
problem you know what I'm saying brother
I can play some golf no no too cold the
golf course to shut down and it's not
like I forgot you know you tell us
freezing yeah it'll be a little warm
today I mean this week so no golf for
you in your Papa now I'll be with family
you want y no we golf will be the film
I love playing golf with with my dad do
you yeah well my golf field I told my
guys did you like your mine the golf you
want talking about a [ __ ] hobby that
takes all your time yeah yeah we can't
go out and just play you know you don't
play well just to hang out like a lot of
times it's not filled with real golfers
yeah well they get snow I'm talking
about like legit you know country club
golfer I mean you're talking about your
day yeah that's a day I like a lot of
people do business like my dad used to
golf all the time he's a lot of business
they always see a lot of networking they
always say that yeah a lot of networking
they always say the same thing though
when you hit a ball get down get down
stay on the fit stay on the fit novo
right ah ah it's hard for me to follow
the ball I feel like it shouldn't be
white that's tell ya he says I feel like
it should be like a bright color well
they do have bright orange a lot of time
you can't play with those don't Li not
it not it not like you're a rich - I
haven't seen I haven't seen them in a
long time now Alma it used to be you
could and now you can't no that's soon
as I hit it if it goes high I'm like I I
never see it usually attract it now they
have the thing though you can track
those chips yeah have you seen one of
those top golf places there's one in uh
I've played it one in Vegas there's one
there's another one I forget where where
they measure your stroke on a computer
nah [ __ ] that noise son it's a driving
range but it's like it's like the cool
place to be it's like a hangout kids go
there in Vegas like a super popular spot
there's you know service there's great
food there's beer and it just you don't
you hit it out there ooh nice yeah it's
sick yeah you know I've seen those No
yeah they're huge now huge huge that
sounds like fun I know right let's go
there I think there's one in LA but it's
not as like the base once the mothership
mmm we should go there I'd be for that
it's a fun time top golf you're firing
the kid holiday party I'm gonna do that
I think there's a top golf in LA June
but I don't know I'll Drive that [ __ ]
there you go top car it makes sense
though because it makes it cool too
you know like you have drinks there's
good food I feel like every athlete who
retires plays golf am i right like every
football player of your baseball player
I don't know I think it's too slow for
most it's so boring as [ __ ] I'll tell
you what Michael Jordan is obsessed they
say his long game no his short game is
it on the planet many thoughts but of
course my kid ego yeah like a maze well
no news for a long one yeah yeah scratch
golfer know what you say never mind
that's in Arizona see there's the top
golf one Vegas is there not one in LA I
typed it in glendale's a little far I
thought I was Glendale here
they're cool looking though does it have
a picture of them let's just try why
don't we drive two hours to Glendale why
don't we sit in traffic yeah see the
thing I tweeted yesterday the picture of
traffic do you have that chin no oh my
god yeah look at these beautiful hill
there the one has a pool on top of it
there's flat screen that's really cool
it's like a cool hangout yeah that's a
really cool right another great idea I
love it I love that now I'm gonna head
nor to me some nice buffalo chicken wing
oh yeah and get sauced up yeah not on
the club there ah like the feels like to
you know finger food and golf don't
really show you like your club to be a
little orange that looks awesome for
like UFC fights even yeah bad idea not a
bad idea at all play some golf watch
some UFC fights yeah get that lounge in
the back mm-hmm super yeah I can't
believe there's not one in LA a great
idea these started in Japan I think this
is what they would do in Japan because
they're so fanatical about golf but
there's very little room there's no you
know done with those enclosed driving
range yeah I don't know if they took it
to this level though did they be not
probably not pretty wild it's just top
golf Los Angeles but nothing you hear
about these are these guys are trapped
in a submarine right now
Oh as we're hanging out about this no we
have about a week left of hockey you
know I know what we're there
I think there's somewhere in Russia or
something they have a we makin worth of
I don't know they have a week's worth of
oxygen and you're down why can't we get
water
well getting an a' submarine up I guess
the surface with all the pressure like
the submarine can break apart it's a
very yeah I know that was this yeah I
don't know I don't know man
they're they're trying to fit look that
up chin so you figure out why these guys
are shot how do you you know the golf
one though that one's coming to El
Segundo City later sick so nothing here
yet so some ring some we don't know what
they are I'm sure to come up so many
people trapped yeah Argentina yeah no
that one no no no no ones it's that just
happened by the way yeah but where's the
one you're talking about be I don't have
lost important practices all of them are
Argentine here that has to be the ones
so yeah they're hopeful they're still
alive oh so it's gone man since
underwater they say they only have a
week left of oxygen yeah 33 chapter and
minors that was oh no that was for the
money but the people that survived that
are telling these people to keep hope
alive I mean by the way you're
underwater we have a vessel hold up so
you're on let's just so we in our
factory it's 44 people on the submarine
it's not that it can't go up they can't
find the submarine yeah oh it's vanished
Oh cuz you could go down and fit you
know somebody's go down up all the time
man I'm convinced it that if the 33
Chilean miner survived our 44 are also
going to come out okay and I get that
and I like your positive thinking
however that's the ocean if you deep
under the ocean that's a real tough one
could there be anything worse can you
name any situation worse
when you're in a submarine thousands of
Thousand Leagues Under the Sea
yeah and something goes wrong right well
I know I'm trying to think of how you
how did you run this guy in a world and
there's nothing like you know like on
I'll figure it out I'm outta here you're
done I'm gonna swim to the top yeah well
that was I got to take it in Russia when
they when they had that one of the
weapons or something was breaking down
and the guys had to go in and D
fused it or something and they they knew
they were gonna die of radiation
poisoning under the sea Me's [ __ ]
some terrible [ __ ] that goes on yeah I
don't know how do you how does that
happen does it do you just run out of
air and do you just suffer we only have
so many days I guess nobody knows it's
not like there's so many days that you
gotta come up and down refuel you know
stop breathing
I would kill everybody on board so they
yeah and then I'd have more oxygen good
idea if I don't know why they're more
submarine movies there need to be what
happened why did you get up and fart
like that you're 50 bro I'll pee too
what we see about El Segundo real quick
jin.o TopGolf was supposed to go there
but I guess it backed off the deal the
City Council get backed off the deal so
no more TopGolf in El Segundo damn it
all right back to the submarine though
yeah we found out that you can live for
seven days or oxygen to only last seven
days in a submerged submarine Oh so
here's what's Argentina's miss submarine
what we know if the sub is bobbing
adrift on the surface and the hatch is
open we'll have available air supplying
enough food for about 30 days but if
it's emerged it cannot raise a snorkel
it's oxygen may last only about seven
days damn so if it's if they can't find
it and it sit on top of the water for
sure we should be able to find it you
can last 30 days cuz of no food but if
it's under water you got about seven
days that's a long snorkel you need
first thing I do
how long is this thing snorkel first
thing I do is I go you want me to get in
submarine I need it I need a three-mile
long snorkel
I mean submarines are freaky man yeah
they really are if you knew you were
gonna go like say seven days is up would
you try swimming sounds really more of
it but no I think you can't open the
latch in your in the submarine canyon
okay the pressure pressure and the
temperature it's gonna be chilly
freezing you know you're seeing a fish
super deep down oh those are things with
the giant mouths and those huge ones
baby poison
yeah you want oh you want deep so do you
want to just dive from lack
oxygen which isn't the worst thing yet
carbon monoxide poisoning kind of just
pass out yeah or we can open the hatch
water comes in freezing cold you die
instantly yeah they're gonna be pretty
scared or you can go on I guess mozi out
the back of the sub jump in that water
and maybe see a light like oh there's a
light well on the end of light is a
giant fish with faith you've seen that
vision yes I have is light yes to have
and Andy got his penis to really well
I'm pretty sure I think that this penis
those four head I'm pretty sure that's
bro science but maybe it is now here's
the thing you're also in very cold water
and by the way when you get to the
surface if you ever do what you want
it ain't a picnic there either cuz
you're in the middle of the ocean well I
think the might change out of that then
I'd rather be up there breathing air
because I'm an air breather I don't know
about you but I'm an air breather so
yeah some readings are scary aren't they
they're scary and you run down there for
six months and you're all together and
you just everybody's like together you
know and you're and you're bending down
cuz it's very small you're like ah you
know and you're eating together and you
talk to each other again I know and
you're like I'm so horny and then you're
like why are you looking at me like no
dude AHA on a sub like a big dong got
dong on your mind no my this guy weird
that's what they call sandwiches so this
guy knows they look like submarine yep
think about a weird of that not that
weird but yeah it's kind of weird a
submarine sandwich where we call that a
submarine sailing yeah this guy I know
to spend his time very unsub's all the
time all the time and he said you would
get to a point where they kind of run a
little bit out of food like there were
just different things and basically for
the next three weeks you would live on
peanut butter they had a huge tub of
industrial-grade peanut butter and you
put that on [ __ ] crackers and eat
that it's kind of nice
you better have enough water but for
three weeks you ever have one of those
no water around sure have time that's
why I'm serious give us that [ __ ]
yeah well this guy was 37 and he looked
every bit of 83 oh the subarray final
age he old sub yeah they got they got UV
lamps and stuff but you're down under
that water being a dick diver you been
on sub never jumped
donal sub now now you know you know just
jump on if I see you go down there with
high as 150 people come out 75 couples
you know saying mmm you know maybe like
one gay cruise guys couple up you know
I'm saying mmm
now you go back to your wife and you get
back up I'll make sense you know I'm
saying it's that gay for under one six
months bro
six months under the water can we look
at it WOD guess I'd rather Heidi never
hiked North Korea take my chances
they'll be under the water for six
months are you kidding I'll do any
dangerous are they I'd rather attempt to
hide Everest I'm alright right I'll be
in the waters division now what would
you rather do here me I'll be what if
they said alright firing the kid
we're shooting a new show see me like a
mini doc series you guys can pick one of
two things to do and you have to do it
yeah I survived you each get one billion
dollars each so you're set for life
damn villain after taxes Mike yes a lot
of money here's this mini sub by about
the size this room you guys have to
navigate it go underwater yes stay
underwater under a thousand say under a
hundred thousand feet underwater
you guys have to navigate II do all the
research you want you have a week you
guys have navigate standard water you
got to be under them for six months or
we helicopter you in to one of the top
peaks in Mount Everest we'll give you
the gear and but that's it you got
figured out and you got to come back
down but you couldn't do it for six
months and nine hours because the air is
[ __ ] but yeah well no they have
something with um how big is my sub it's
big as this studio now has cots on the
side we got all the industrial peanut
butter we can handle so then water but
that's it no a billion dollars bro I
need more than peanut butter and [ __ ]
give me something else alright there's
some porn magazines no I
why's bro I don't need [ __ ] porn
magazines alright alright you're gonna
have ants on a log
there's celery raisins and peanut butter
you can only answer that sucks bro it's
a billion dollars it was easy everyone
yeah well why are you being a dick about
the celery and the [ __ ] raisin selfie
what was toothless you want can I get a
vegetable can I get something that's
gonna move my fillory and what celery is
a vegetable
it's so nutritionally boy oh there's
nothing there yeah actually it actually
Joshu calories Chinese I just give me
some avocados and some help no no no no
no uh all right so he knows no weird how
you gonna cook them all right you know
I'm gonna give you I'm give you some
dunkaroos you don't know what I don't
want I don't want your junk food dude I
don't want your Aurora junk food I want
smooth cruiser class I don't want some
good stuff wrong body here's what you're
gonna get what you get some celery yeah
some industrial peanut butter yeah some
raisins yeah a little race in the red
box I know
raisins Oberman iron but hear me out
yeah you get one pack of the day you
gotta you gotta monitor yourself you
ration you have one packet of dunkaroos
a day and yeah coffee
a bottle of cheese with coffee it's a
billion dollars
I don't want dunkaroos get him away from
me get him away from me right now get it
oh my god dunkaroos those are the worst
thing you could eat no no they're the
worst thing you could eat I'm not sighs
there's not five Oh
don't god damn it I'm not eating those
dunkaroos I never had one you're
deprived as a child just give me
something with fiber and something
that's gonna make me I want some I need
something on the sub I don't know it's
just wondering that google at you where
do they [ __ ] on something does it just
go out the back is like that ass just a
really good question does it just like
is there like an opening just goes there
has to be right and the fish are like
where does human waste go on a boat
nothing a boat I sub I'm sure they kick
it out sanitary tanks inside the
pressure so it's like a plane usually
pumped overboard it has to all right
yeah same thing in space - right
drug being submarine for six months deep
underwater with all Russians or in space
seven months ah [ __ ] dude yeah I tell
you why you don't want to be in space
the lack of gravity [ __ ] with your bone
density Oh for surmount of time and also
some of the pressure from the submarine
true but a submarine at least you have a
better chance of living if you run out
of heat in
space there's like a weed our boosters
don't work oh then help oh there it goes
will your 70 light-years well alright
can you guys wait till we invent a way
to get hooks oh we can be about your
years if we leave now he had one
thousand miles an hour yeah no thanks
no danke no danke uh I gotta go with the
submarine god I hate it I'm gonna hate
people's jobs man that's tough job NASA
if you're working on that sub yeah
people a father worked on a sub he did
yeah your dad is a big boy you don't
want to be tall on a sub it sucks yeah I
don't know man you figure it out I guess
it's like this I guess it's you're all
you're just living he was uh he's in the
Navy he was on a1 those big-ass ships
ain't worked some on the sub he saves on
the ship and they'd be at sea for
[ __ ] ever and then he goes then we go
to port you know guys you're a bunch of
guys guys just go wild on the Wow and he
goes and I would grab a book and I'd
read and fill the town like no I'm gonna
stop you various what he's all dead
cities I trying to be you know
connecting me cuz I had you know a lot
of guys grad party and meet girls and
have a grand old time and then come back
hungover on the ship grab my favorite
book and I would walk the town and learn
the culture now Dan man that's
interesting now did you have zero
friends or were you gay just two you're
30 how's that work yeah yeah now enjoy
the food I'm a human heart on it by the
time I got that [ __ ] that boat I'm
just like where's the brothel I would
walk in the day do you speak English
because I'm about to boss yeah where can
I good douche is there a good douche
house I'm sorry I'm starving and I don't
give a [ __ ] about food cuz I'm looking
for some [ __ ] to work at this point
that's right I don't anything to put
this flesh submarine dude you don't want
to go in there man you know I know
you're gonna catch do want to go in
there I do wanna go I wanna make my way
through this that's right just like I
did on that boat full do something shut
the [ __ ] up and get me in there right
now my dad could be guys could they good
do they have makeup on good to go clean
shave that closet out eternity that's
and they're cheaper than the real women
whatever I'm in [ __ ] Korea there you
go there you go let's rock and roll
let's rock and roll
yeah you know my dad taught my foot I
need good food wait a toy Wow stroke the
town with a book huh all right man
all right what they when you got back on
the ship would they hold you down and
bully or out that worked my pop almost
married a Japanese woman different
[ __ ] right he did he was marine yeah
and he was and he had to call it off he
had to go he said I went to her house
and I fell in love with the with the
Japanese was dating her seriously can't
do it before your mother was just as
like more before my mom before my mom
what yeah because they weren't together
when he was in the Marines
hey hey papa yeah
is this World War two yeah you traitor
hey papa tell you trying to marry a
[ __ ] Japanese woman man doctor those
frown upon dad's a goddamn gentleman
though my dad my dad went small without
a smaller japanese girl yeah cuz his
friend yeah little Japanese girl cuz his
back then remember in Japan apparently
before World War two there was never
there's no such thing as a 6-foot tall
Japanese person not just a diet an
onside yeah but he went there and his
buddy broke up with a girl he'd been
dating and never told her and just got
back on the ship my father had no
respect that he was like I don't like
that you can't do that so he went and he
talked to her and said I you know he
spoke a little Japanese and he had it
was a very teary breakup for her white
Godzilla that it's like a giant hairy
gods Oh have you ever seen them mean the
this what I picked is because you have a
piece on you so I'm sure you pop account
yeah he's the original yeah so is that
big old
Saban yeah have you ever seen my mother
my mother quote my mother's is that I
just really disrespect my mother goes
it's pretty enormous it's pretty
enormous hey when I picture your dad
with that little Japanese girl have you
ever seen the meme of Shaq where it
shows it shows a squirrel try neat this
fat like cucumber shacking this little
girl have you ever seen that and it shut
yeah it shows like this little like cute
squirrel trying to eat this fat [ __ ] you
like eggplant yeah it's a disaster yeah
look that's why I picked the [ __ ]
look at the size of Shaq with his girl
look my buddy James Hunt who is uh who's
a hot of a basketball coach he has the
pictures of him that I show you this
pictures of him at six foot four
guarding shiny talks about crazy yeah
yeah how funny is that meme though
Hawaii
let's not pictured your dad with the
Japanese girl yeah that's what it was
like
she's probably grateful shut her mouth
probably hurt look at that little
chipmunk yeah how funny is that though
it's a babe what how different your life
would be if you're half Japanese man I
know I'd be I don't know where I'd be
living damn his dad had to break it off
yeah I had to break it off
he dad likes the Japanese oh yeah oh
yeah yeah prefers get a real pen Sean
you know peg Sean talked about girls
with you ever we might have never had
much man my dad my dad was he's the old
school guy man oh it was Holloway yeah
old school marine you know they really
don't talk like that yeah you know I was
at the I went on this this you know with
Todd and his wife in Mean Joe were there
and we're talking about kid stuff like
that and Todd said he was there you
might cuz you and your wife are
different you're different but he said
they're talking about fraternity for
Turk fraternity fraternity for fraternal
no no like - no no no like when you have
enough you know sperm to get the
fertility for - yes
fertility so they're talking about that
he said the doctor for his wife was like
how much are you jacking off Susie brown
bubble
there's something really it's really
when they're close to how masturbating
on it when are you doing it how often
you do it where are you doing it I'm
like Jesus Christ yeah yeah and then Joe
is like when when do you jack off only
God I'm not when I'm an open book but
this is kind of weird to me
I had a check-up when I was a young man
and my doctor was this Stern it was in
Connecticut I'll never forget it I was
probably in high school I might have
been I was playing college or just after
and he was this stirrer
New England Puritan just a tall stern
man and in New England and Connecticut
especially it's changing now but there
was a formality there was a very strong
English influence it was a formality to
things and the doctor would come in
check me out and they said yes
are you having unprotected sex how old
are you I was probably twenty maybe
nineteen ology I detect unprotected sex
and I was like oh this is very awkward
well first of all doc the answer is 100%
and of course in fact I don't believe in
condoms and of course I will do that for
the rest of my life yes meanwhile I was
like never I sure did I didn't want him
to stick in a cotton swab up my dong
have you have you ever gone to get
tested your hand and they asked you for
all the stuff you like but you're there
to solve a problem but you find yourself
a lying oh yeah how many sexual partners
have you had in the past three months
like yes will you try to go through it
but you still like dirt bags and still
like dirt bag so as many as I can sir as
many as I can it's a full time how many
do you think folks are exhausted I
barely got a better getting here I [ __ ]
so much I'm exhausted all the time my
balls are always empty I just need you
give me the goddamn medication and get
rid of this runny dude that's right we
have to go over this yep I'm a
reoccurring customer I can tell you I
don't need a test tell you right now I'm
100% positive for whatever I've been
around this block enough where I don't
need you to inspect me a question got
the clap sir this guy didn't give me
those [ __ ] pills so I get that all I
know is I'm on a piece I made the walk I
need you just give me my goddamn two
scoops I get out of here
matter of fact I'm a VIP member of this
club my friend my friend cause Brian
Brian what is [ __ ] what I got warts oh I
as we're not good I said show me your
dick I can't with their warts off show
me your dick now yeah he had never heard
of any war oh that's no problem that is
very prevalent warts yeah or the old war
tolas are that's I don't think Sophie I
think in the older generation not he's
you're worse than the most common they
are the most common they are a day yeah
I remember when my buddy did that and I
said to my to my doctor I go can you
check me I didn't know I was so paranoid
you know and he's like oh they're
epidemic yeah but I was good I was good
what every common we wanna three million
US cases a year
hey what's the number one STD do that I
believe genell with genital warts most
common own you can have a vaccine look
at most common sounds good there you go
most common STD chlamydia gonorrhea
herpes three aids for human papilloma
virus but I'm sure it's I think it's I'm
sure i'm pato most positive oh you know
what though you got to do in the United
States
oh you did HPV yeah there you go HPV
human papillomavirus that is warts there
you go warts yet it's human
papillomavirus that is that is what
causes genital warts human papilloma
papilloma virus there you go
warts warts they're everywhere
kids get him and then cause is about 900
cuz she's already in the water drains of
yes so many different strains I've never
had a ward of you yeah I want to say hey
people can get on their face is there no
chance in the world you wake up in
morning go ahh there's three long
whiskers but people have them on their
but they get them on there but just so
you know but but whatever you're faced
with that fat block and then they take
them off and they cause a scar I'd
rather have a scar I talked to a doctor
I'd rather starve say the three winners
get warrants on their face she goes oh
yeah I gotta take them off
yet they scarf oh yeah it's important
your buns though but yeah your elastic
sir give that wart to wart on your fader
some people are susceptible to warts
some people they say if you have if you
get herpes on your lip you have a better
chance of knocking it on your dick
because you have a natural immunity to
it all kinds of things about sexual
transmitted diseases things you should
know if you're if you if you [ __ ] you
know people are generally warts John
safe people are generally no warts on
the face people are born with them oh
yeah know some dude somewhere with warts
on their faith oh yeah I had them on my
hands man yeah I don't mind hater hey
don't make fun of us hey just cuz you
don't have a word full of you are you
guys a kid you get them on yeah I will
cut them off myself
really yeah they go back if you go
freeze away no there's that stuff you
can buy at Walgreens CVS where it just
freezes it doesn't really work amantha
you get to go travel they have that cut
those [ __ ] off in the shower you like
holy [ __ ] really yes I'd do it you had
warts all over you dick and stuff no I
didn't have my dick I don't know we're
talking about my hands bro you had warts
all day man is one of my foot bottom my
foot as a kid that was that didn't feel
good you know had one like your nose or
something no man did I warts on the face
is tough yeah hey see your grandma had a
mold in right [ __ ] a wart no it's a mole
it's at all did anyone here to take it
off but just moles she's still alive I
could ask her when we get out of here I
guess
no he's got a roll with that bro yeah I
have always had skin issues bolsa rias's
I got [ __ ] you know cancer herpes and
lip yeah I got all kinds of skin there's
good on man in 50 years you're doing all
right you don't have anything Syrian I'm
strong you thought those cancer it was
kind of um sort of moles but moles can
be scared on your face cuz they can it
can lead to cancer right or certain of
warts certain strains of warts can but
moles not a ward is it I'm sorry a mole
is not a word I'm always a cluster of
skin cells it is not a war but it's not
a war so those moles can be cute man
yeah
Milana like Apple I've loved a black
mole on my nutsack that is born with
yeah you do yeah
black mole yeah is it tiny tiny little
dot yeah it's been there since I was a
kid yeah I'm a nut we take a look at it
all right after this you're not out and
you know it's crazy
my son is the same thing really yep
exact same spot too really yep
it's interesting you ever just peel your
sash table nuts mmm chopped nuts shout
you shop not shop nothin if my dad has
it
you ever get can't wanna find out next
time I'm in Denver and my dad goes to
gym he just walked around that [ __ ]
gym like he owns place with his dick out
puts his leg up tries to talk to me and
[ __ ] like everything's all good and all
the years of fighting you down as a bush
yeah yeah Bush you get lost at Birds
hide what is that what is the deal
sparrows fly out in the morning they
have bushes I don't believe in trimming
my dad my dad is who could give a [ __ ]
my dad's never seen a razor they're like
they're in a 70s porno you'd be
considered a communist if you cut your
hair that the hair on your dong that's
the old school dudes man my dad barely
trims and heroness nostrils oh he'll
discuss it up I'm looking up it is not
all I know and it's like whispering like
dude it connects to their [ __ ] his
goddamn eyebrows are growing did I hear
you man dude can would it kill you my
dad's looking really good lately 77 your
mom would like you got to cut your Bush
I mean they don't care if they're a
while
that's Ryu don't [ __ ] it but I mean yeah
he's it's not comfortable though like
you've never Bush it's uncomfortable I
feel like I I keep that [ __ ] trim
because I want to see everything
me too not if my fans that look bigger
to begin with yeah yeah
how important is big dicks to guys so
you and I that's literally probably the
most important thing somewhere in some
ways no I just need could be a prompt
like you know how like I don't I always
take my height for granted I'll like I
don't give a [ __ ] it so I don't this is
my perspective see but if when you're
short you can't see think about your
hands right if that dick yeah you don't
think about fat dick but if you have a
tiny dick I'm sure it's something you
can't sell function long you'll build
skyscrapers and star wars
you have to yeah yeah yeah that's a
motor basketball teams become president
you do enough like you want whatever you
got to do yeah you get that dick chip on
your shoulder got a dick too so you got
a hope you kid had a small dick maybe
what with our with our handsome and
wonderful friend Cody Donovan I love
when I start talking to him I'll just
stare at his hands cuz he's such a big
Viking but his hands are like my size
yeah and and he doesn't like having
small hands cuz Cody's a macho
[ __ ]
yeah and I'll just look at him and I'll
go what's going on with y'all hands I
did this to Tariq I see him too I'll be
like this target Ana Tariq has small
hands oh he certainly does I had only
got it no my hands are bared well he
does too and so I can I can that's
they're both of them that's their
kryptonite both those guys awesome guys
confident I just goods and I'll go whoo
y'all hands for sewing huh I go right
over the table I'm done cookie forever
I've never noticed you had smaller I
took him in weird I think he had some
son of a [ __ ] Cody good-looking dudes a
good-looking [ __ ] dude right he's
just a real man me and Cody and a smart
guy literally one of my closest friends
for a Miss I know me too me too me too
me see Road Dogg's you were only the
best the best well he's a smart guy he's
a very smart wicked smart yeah wicked
wicked smart didn't go to college either
really I don't think he could teach her
too easy like well the best teachers I
know stupid smart yeah he's very very
very smart and creative
I bet very good artist I believe I've
always I've always got that from him
yeah he's a Johnny Bryan man okay look
at his beard could he be more of a
Viking like a good guys guy yeah you
know what he's also hilarious yeah he's
also very very funny yeah he's running
the high altitude out there now yeah
it's it's his own gym well we that's
what I remember like he dreamed a logo
like the it's a it's a what he caught
the Iceman the UH the abominable snowman
he heard that their logo like that's out
gilman artists waken artists Donnybrook
Cody hey died Cody somebody tell Cody to
come [ __ ] visit us in LA it'd be nice
Jesus he's a hater though hater
come out here hates us you know he was
gonna move out here I was gonna he was
gonna move out here when he you know
he's using it yeah yeah but I'm Mary it
was obviously teaching was his first
love I loved its first love it's
something he's really good at yeah
British blades the ice Curtis blades
head coach he's writing up your number
not in the world right now Daniel no cut
he's only good ones man yeah well the
best people I've ever met
smart smart kid wife Julia is a kid now
it's awesome his wife is Vietnamese or
Philippines I think she's being a music
that's her right
you would know too I was saying good
that's good breeding stock that you got
Viking and Filipino or maybe you know
how Filipino could be Vietnamese I think
she's might be right be yeah I went to
there uh sure she's Vietnamese in the
wedding give the best man speech how
about you know how coating her met me
and Cody there's my first fight oh he's
like third fight at the Ring of Fire I
knocked my down like 13 seconds Cody
knocked his guy out in like 10 seconds
and we're in the like in the hallway
area where all the fans are you know we
don't want [ __ ] so no one's really
coming up to us and we're getting beers
and hotdogs celebrating cuz just went
through camp together and these two
girls came up to us like yo can we get a
picture Alec correct code him like I
could get used to that like something
super lame I'm like I could get used to
this and they take a picture and they
walk away and Cody goes dude that girl
I'm like yeah take it easy
we're just starting out let's not
[ __ ] jump teeth he's like no that
girl man oh my god I'm like relax Jesus
he's the only dates agents only like
agents since I've known him he's like
Godzilla and so he won't stop harping on
that girl two years later they run into
each other and start dating it shows him
that picture damn that [ __ ] wife you
know that's his wife yeah damn beautiful
story yeah yeah I think she's Vietnamese
she looks Vietnam Vietnam essentially
essentially the only contracting thing
that's actually never been conquered
peep this her dad her dad flew planes in
World War 2 for the Americans on time
Vietnam Vietnam in Vietnam yeah for the
American
yeah won't say bombed his countrymen
well no she might have been hmong she
might have been home so long of the
mountain people of Vietnam no she's not
because the hmong were allied themselves
with american no no she was part of this
program i forget what it was
we'll have to opt ASCO to get all the
facts for her bro scientist she's not
Hmong definitely monk something happened
we're yeah he started flying well the
South Vietnamese were aligned for a long
time with the Americans right it's not
that we get the exact story I forget
what it is super interesting we did
fight along with South Vietnamese so
that was how it was so it makes sense
any flew jets for the Americans or
certainly for South Vietnam it's a more
accurate description yeah Cody Donovan
doing the damn thing gets a little
critter now though there you go and some
random owls in the middle of this
picture
hey Cody get better social media huh
some random mouths really place on your
head yeah with some curt events - yeah
corrine events with chin dog chin dog
jun-chan I can't wait yet I can't wait
61 year old limo driver is gonna build
where he's building his own rocket
he's flying off this week in it now is
Eddie Bravo funding it earth is round
this is not highly disputed fact unless
you're a member of the 16th century
Roman Inquisition or the rapper b.o.b
and yet thanks to these guys actually
really believe the earth is flat
a small but this small but dedicated
group of people still convinced earth is
flat so yes one of these so-called flat
earthers the guy named Mad Mike Hughes
and Hughes 61 year old limo driver has
spent the past few years building a
homemade steam-powered rocket in his
garage to prove he's right he's a rocket
scientist and also in a limo driver yeah
scroll down because he doesn't really
hasn't spent a lot of time looking at
this so rocket is
ready this Saturdays Hughes will climb
aboard and launch himself and the rotten
trees for sure gonna die so say goodbye
now man Mike and the rocket up into the
air hoping to move one step closer to
demonstrate him once and for all that
the world as we know is actually a flat
disc with a giant wall of ice around it
like Game of Thrones giant wall of ice
around it fascinating he actually flew I
don't even science I don't believe in I
know about aerodynamics and fluid
dynamics and how things move through the
air about the certain size of rocket
nozzles and thrust but that's not
science that's just a formula there's no
difference between science and science
fiction he launched his rocket it was
costing about 20 grand to build and is
sponsored by the group research Flat
Earth Saturday over Amboy a ghost town
in California he hits he expects to hit
speeds I love this be if you're not
scared to death you're an idiot mmm
it's carousel but notice again out of
this world alive I like to do
extraordinary things that no one else
can do well no a bunch of people could
do and no one is designed built and
launched himself in his own rocket
there's a reason for there be a reason
for that clear reason for the whoa when
he launched he's already took the skies
back when he launched himself 1374 feet
into the air and earlier rocket he
survived but reportedly needed three
days to return the effects of the
g-forces Oh
Saturday's launch will be available to
watch live on the internet pay-per-view
we should have done companion he's gonna
shoot straight up in the air so he can
do what see if the earth is flat he's
gonna break why didn't he just get in a
plane and look out the [ __ ] window
you don't go high enough you leave the
atmosphere the planes aren't given do it
so he's gonna go leave the atmosphere
and then float down in a what in a with
a parachute that's how he did his
initial rocket launch
see the big flat Necco wafer that is our
planet with his I wants to eventually be
able to do that he says nothing is out
of reach anything can be done you just
have to put enough money time and
thought into it right that's Jake
flattered so everybody's lying except
for the flat earthers about the earth
being flat so Newtonian physics and
Einstein is
and all that I guess those guys were
liars huh I wonder how this ends for
this guy probably you know how to ends
ah [ __ ] it's round two that's how this
story ah [ __ ] it's rep cuz you it's just
gonna be [ __ ] it's rep push it's just
it's we'll be watching live and he's
like [ __ ] it's right move oh my god I'm
not flattered through my fake news it's
alright system don't act in the system
g-forces that's very quick he's gonna be
blasting through the air you know it's
actually pretty round as [ __ ] it's
actually very round everybody
as I said my entire life oh god
he said go tell my kids oh he's kind of
I guess he knows how to make a rocket
build a rocket yes so he's doesn't look
crazy at all in that picture
no I mean looks like it [ __ ] together
this is gonna be this I got this
Saturday
pay-per-view only I'm I would I would
probably pay we should have a companion
for this yeah to see him go I see he's
gonna come out and go it's flat it's so
I bet he starts crying he's gonna be up
there like flat earther seven hair what
do you see so I guess he's gonna
videotape us think what's also when he's
gonna shoot himself up and then the
parachutes gonna come out I hope that
works and then as he's floating down
he's gonna kind of look she's gonna take
pictures who knows how he's he's yeah
he's also gonna have a GoPro chime on
his head or you want to see his first
launch yes I sure do check my head
rocket flight 200,000 views poor dude
built a rock you know yet
goddamn that's a really Roth
that is so ingenuity should raise a
rocket scientist but he drives a limo
mm-hmm yeah oh well he's not very high
is he and look at that parachute he
didn't go very high
a thousand nice - robber teen hundred
feet a horse and head yeah I don't
understand I used to rock
I used to launch a bunch of rockets when
I was a kid that parachute is on oh that
didn't last very long and he didn't go
that high
hmm here's some film by Mike Hawkins of
Paramount Pictures paramedics god damn
it Michael
that is gutsy that parachute was very
full of holes when I was seven eyes
thing about doing [ __ ] like this yeah
yeah you've seen maybe did we ever play
that thing where the guy catches a
rabbit using two snakes yes yeah what's
that through this guy just people who do
crazy [ __ ] Oh picking up tiger snake
expect the most poisonous by the tail
here you go
that's smarter than this I think so I
think it is yeah it is we can practice
with that this is crazy
there's only one go oh and nASA has
problem
launching huge rocket to the sky and
they have issues all the time and then
NASA you limo driver amateur limo driver
Bill rocket dude that was a few things
serious [ __ ] rocket - right it will
didn't go that high though god damn it
scary thing you wanna last all the chief
forces you survive but report in 83 this
guy's awesome yeah he's a little bit
awesome he's gonna die though for sure
yeah I hope not
is his death Saturday oh I hope he
doesn't die because he doesn't deserve
to die
no he's just crazy yeah maybe hurt the
ground so hard he'll see the world's
round house this end for him I want to
see a big flat Necco wafer how the [ __ ]
does he not have a 10th planet logo on
his rocket you sure I didn't Betty not
jump on board on
I don't know Eddie get on it what else
yet gin Wow
take a look Oh so Lavar ball and Donald
Trump you guys saw that at CNN interview
or have you know have you seen this he
was hard on CNN it's very weird though
he didn't argument let's see it watch
this B you love this that's Chris pretty
long but then FC some of it did you ever
think that you would be on CNN
discussing geopolitics and the President
of the United States never in my wildest
dreams so why aren't his teeth like this
dream let's discuss how we got here
your son was with UCLA they're playing
ball over in China they get detained
with allegations that they stole
merchandise from a store the president
finds out about it he of course is in
China he's meeting with President Marcos
harden gets involved the boys are
released they get to come back home
which was never a certainty until he got
involved he says that yo how do you know
it how do you know it wasn't involved
before I even knew that I mean he didn't
even know they was over there and like
Ted okay what was the reason for him
going over there in the first place the
president was in China to meet with the
president of China and discuss trade
matters but he certainly was informed
and that's the boys when he was in China
and that's why he got involved he says
okay he didn't get involved who he got
to China I don't understand she wasn't
going over there beforehand he was going
over there what are you trying it wasn't
like he was in the US and said okay
there's three kids in China I need to go
over there and get him coincidence your
kids were there right what we're talking
about right now is a lot of stuff about
my son just because his last name is
ball we're not even talking about the
other two kids you just wants talk about
we should be honest talking about your
thank you we're talking about your son
what about my son - right but we're
talking about our son because this
hostile and what you said this isn't
cooking on your son it's because of how
you it's when somebody asks me a
question that's not disrespectful if I
feel nobody
did anything I don't have to say go
around saying thank you to everybody I
mean you don't have to go around shake
his hand he didn't have to say that but
I'm just saying if I have to know what
somebody's doing before I say thank you
I'm gonna stop I'll go around saying
thank you okay so lets you come and
shake my hand and meet me or meet my son
or anybody and then say you know what
maybe I can help you out
okay let's do it that way but this guy's
so confused on the left yeah there's
just a lot of that and then just then he
go I need you to thank me right now or
no no yes the CNN guy to thank him to
use thank you Oh daddy thank me for
being on CNN and you think they're
joking around back and forth to you a
little bit so did ya the hue startled
they both started laughing and playing
with each other the guy on the left was
like the bottom on is that Donald Trump
was injured in China and he did take
time to talk to the president about
getting the kids out of jail and it was
directly because of his actions I can
guarantee probably that those kids got
influenced really worse yet they would
yeah so don't want to give it up Donald
Trump replied through Twitter after the
interview and of course it's smart out I
was wrong ball they're the same kind of
person both a couple of ego mania right
just keep it a thug okay he said we've
been over this he called him a UH Don
King without a wig or good hung King
without hair yeah there's Lavar balls
just Don King without here and he goes
like ungrateful fool here it is
poor man's Don King huh it's so New York
so [ __ ] New York just back and forth
let's silly was just frozen what a
sketch in Oh North Korea South Korean
spies went over and said that North
Korea is actually banning partying so
you can't drink sing and all stuff
because they don't want anyone outside
information coming in they don't want
people to be celebrating well yeah yeah
I don't think anybody has any doubts but
the North Koreans are the worst that
their regime is the worst in the world
and not only that
don't entire families entire families
disappear in the middle of the night
yeah I'll take so you [ __ ] up they take
you and your whole family into a prison
camp yep and just cost you in there yeah
with your children yeah that's when you
live on a cornmeal and salty soup well
really water what a piece of [ __ ] man
well the worst it's it's a true monarchy
in the old school days such a bummer II
just can't just go in there and blow
them up I know you just can't it's
people evil place yes yeah but also he
can't party or seeing in North Korea I
don't think it was trying to party or
things well they do D and also
apparently she who's the president of
China he does not miss the secret is he
does not like this young [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay young dude yeah he does not like
him John what did he do somebody because
Kim's budget right he's just good
bargaining chip maybe but he's also he's
also a mess yeah yeah he's also crazy
man it's it's such a shame that that
goes on in the world you can't really
you know it's like well that's if
anybody needs to die it's that guy him
yeah I agree
if anybody needs to die should I blow up
the whole regime hit the hole so you
just restart you know yeah that's I
can't believe no one's got together like
all the countries like we can't have
this right well China Russia China
Russia and Russia are the biggest
influences on North Korea
so China and Russia really are the ones
who have to make the left doing Kahoot
to go though right they all try to go to
war has always been used as somewhat of
a bargaining chip in a geopolitical
perspective you know I just can't
believe our the world leaders don't sit
around like do we I guess yeah we can't
it's 2.17 we can't have this he's a
nuisance but you know at the at the at
the same time North Korea is also you
know just this it's in their relevant
country in the grand scheme I know but I
did all that
yeah look at I'm saying look at how
people are suffering though yeah that
our world leaders want to help out with
that take a look at something guys now
these guys are on their coats cuz it's
cold all right look at the guys standing
there and their shirts who knows how
long they have to stand there but they
are not wearing shoe one the two guys
standing at attention behind them right
there
gloves on in full bodysuits I don't know
that looks like a shirt that doesn't
look like a jacket and it looks like
it's cold out there
you stand stretch be not really the
truck drivers there's no uniforms I know
but I bet you it's cold and I bet you
that that's just one layer too late well
he's definitely a jerk that doesn't care
about other people for sure look a
horrible look at him I just feel like I
wish somebody would cut his [ __ ] head
off right there it's tough to do right
get out there and do it well the penalty
is you know what else we got alright
more North Korea last week or two weeks
ago a North Korean soldier defected so
he basically just jumped across the
border and when you do that you know the
North Korean military is gonna start
shooting try and kill you he actually
made it he just shot five times it was
caught on camera
Wow but he's alive he's alive shot five
times he's in a Korean hospital right
South Korean Hospital just a bit of him
get away yeah I'll show you some parts
of it so damn you see this cuz if you
cross the line they shoot you right yeah
you can get and they in South Korea
North Korea like they're face to face
the lion so when when when East and West
Berlin were separated by a wall you saw
this a lot this is your chin
that's a soldier crossing right now in a
jeep in a Jeep and they're firing at him
right now not on he's fine right here so
this is still the North Korean side he
just said [ __ ] and I've had enough yeah
so he comes here he's coming in hot
coming in hot in this Jeep which is
probably alarming everybody it is
alarming all the soldiers around there
Lisa green around there
terrible basis look here some a guy
escaped from East Germany in a hot air
balloon do you know yeah that's on Vice
so this worries out and though you'll
see some other angles here no no I'm so
this is when they realize that's them
trying to get up yeah that's they try
again from crossing I know in their
country yeah the prey don't get much
action damn it he made it there that's
him running from the Jeep and these
people they're just straight-up fine
yeah that one guy fell damn before he
make it
how did he make you man and so if you
try they just shoot you did try and
shoot you dead if you try to cross
they'll try to shoot you you can't leave
you can't decision I can't believe that
goes on to them so how these guys get
punished for not getting them for sure
yeah you probably killed all of them for
nothing
yeah well I'm like dude I hate them
that's what happens now that I have not
hit them
so that's all the North Korean troops
just gathering like figure out what's
gonna what they're gonna do next and
then I'll show you here that's him after
he crossed into the South Korea side
he's hiding mounted pillar a a wall and
he's shot five times already in the back
property this is the South Korean
military ROK Marines crawling through on
their side you can see the heat to get
them yeah to grab them damn that's so
cool story obvious for all his families
over in South Korea yeah and I'll put
them they'll kill all the family their
family pays the price for it what the
[ __ ] what a badass again a straight
badass man desperate times call for
desperate measures
damn right doctors guys have
everything's OC but nothing he found out
he had parasites in his body which they
found sighing oh damn it so they'd lose
some motor functions so Olaf's 50% of
his blood doctors consider amputate in
one of his arms else state that oh his
name's Oh would lose some motor function
through the severity of his injuries Oh
was also found to have dozens of
parasites some as long as 27 centimeters
intestines which were nutrition health
in North Korea's yeah the curd the South
Korean doctor said he had never seen
anything like this unless except for in
textbooks his parasites
think about that they're living in hell
and that's the that's the military they
actually eat better than I know it makes
you want it you're not going to do
something it makes you want to liberate
them these are human beings they're
suffering Manute Bol his team teammate
Jason Williams said that he could have
been 50 years old when he was playing
how about that they told me balls aged
and said he could have played him to his
fifties
because they're like now you know he
said I think he's dink I knew--i
you see that
tribal markings on his forehead that
would be I think he's Dinka they're the
tallest people in the world in the Sudan
scroll down gin here's a little piece of
trivia well let me read this before you
keep dropping knowledge for a second
they made seven-foot Center widely
recognized birthday 1962 his coach at
the time and that got him in he just
gave him that perfect night eight I gave
him his birthday because they didn't
know how old he was sky Bowl had no idea
of his age and the kid he came over with
didn't know how old he was either no one
knew well the immigration people were in
the office at Cleveland State they
thought it was great they loved it they
were big fans of Cleveland State they
skimmed our games the one to cover
themselves because Manute was starting
to get so much publicity his picture was
in the papers on the six o'clock news he
was such a different looking guy than
everyone else at that time no one had
ever seen anything like it it's like
dude we gotta come up with everything
and then that's where Jason every off
like doors open at 19 every athletic
door is closed when you're 35
he's probably 40 50 years old when his
plane no I don't believe wait here it is
here's his teammates in it Bowl was list
at 28 years old when he began playing
for the Sixers in 1990 but will his
believes he was actually twice that age
hue sad to say that he was 35 year old
but used to be on the bench looking at
all the circles and scars around his
head and asked him one day Manu what are
those scars on your head he says well
the white man lost my berths to be in
the jungle so every five years I'd have
to take a rock and sliced one across my
head I was like all right and then I
started looking at the next game and
said holy [ __ ] oh that's actually not
true that story he told him is not when
you're when you're Dinka or when you're
newer that's a very common tribal
scarring did you get actually as you get
into manhood keep this though Manu
Paul's son is like the number one
recruit in America no he's my brother
sent me a video and he just signed with
Oregon he's a super baller he's 72 I
tell about 5-star recruits just signed
with Oregon yeah he's if you look to
watch the highlights on his son yeah
super freak bring up Dinka bring up the
Dinka take a look at how they live they
live off of their their cattle their
their tribesman their herders and the
nua as well and take a look at their
tribal markings and and they
are it's very common see 7-foot people
and there are the tallest people in the
world see that they all do that there
are fascinating to have that are yes
there are an amazing looking people just
keep going through those pictures oh
[ __ ] go to that one with that guy with
the bloody face but not left up left
they cover themselves in ash yeah so
that's that's a rite of passage to be a
hard pass so that could be a way to mark
how many years there they've been alive
then all right no because that's that's
that's not that is something you get as
you you are a man yes so it's tribal
scoring it's an initiation and the Nuala
who are look exactly alike and they're
sworn enemies
they're sworn enemies so it has nothing
to do with racism it's it's tribal in
life they they have different tribal
markings and that's the way you can tell
but they are so from living in Saudi
Arabia and being around a lot of
Sudanese you can always tell us Sudanese
they're tall as [ __ ] they are just
incredible new ball just say his age now
who gives a [ __ ] I don't know he'd be
cooler if you died that's amazing do you
really think passed away he did yeah we
do died yeah yeah damn don't live all
that tall take a look at that you bring
up those cows do me a favor chin mm-hmm
um yeah go to go to where the cows are
where they're standing on this they
stand up on these am I on the right one
this one no over there it's just third
one this yeah that's yeah now you see it
arrow all the way when you're indeed but
see that how he's they overlook the cows
and they live on those cows they drink
the blood they drink the milk they
essentially live on blood and milk and
they are a [ __ ] gang up sometimes a
fist below 8 feet so go over to that go
over to that tongue arrow there and just
click it see that's there you go then
they put ash on their bodies turn
different rituals so now you got seven
footers and they covered in white ash
basement your tutor than that oh that's
true look at that that's a woman right
there look at the women look I was
taller there good and that dude
very calm means while they're so tall
communist he is said like six foot eight
woman
yeah rather warlike - yes look you know
just a boy that's what--that's he's
going through his ritual doesn't mean at
the major war going on to Civil War
terrible terrible the Sudan was really
really horrible ease yeah let's take a
look at this so a nurse catfished other
women into into making them send like
nudes and explicit public pictures and
online nurse post is fake doctor to
catfish sexually harass other women
including ownership a said after she
posed as a male doctor on social media
and dating lives I didn't even use voice
changing software to check wound and
sending her explicit text and photos
that's not her by the way I'll show you
a picture that's her
she's so the 20 Sarah who worked out a
nurse at Cross House hospital in Kilmer
at Scotland even convinced some of the
victims into sharing images keeps going
down she was Miss Scotland finalist no
she tricked him miss Scotland finalist
Oh her web of lies was finally revealed
after she attempted to whoa model Abby
Draper and visit AHA flow to see her
dying grandfather oh my gosh she would
always say that she has like tragedies
going on in her life like her father's
dying or sicker dude to gaming she goes
my granddad this is not the crazy lady
talking but one of the victims goes my
granddad was 80 years old had suffered a
stroke was in the care of this unhinge
women who's not qualified to take care
of those sick things you get off on
basically Doctor Strange right yeah yeah
like show me your tits that's her again
oh she's good she's got her own issues
in perversions Jesus Christ man what a
sketch in I think that should be it
oh wait I do want to know this one
kendall Jenner she she topped Gisele
Bundchen has a highest paid model lot
jesus crushin was since 2002 well that's
impressive
Gisele you know I was like it legit
supermodel Ken you know no I'm not
saying Kendall's on a model but how
crazy that
Kendall Jenner's earnings of 22 million
over the past 12 months have more than
doubled from 2016 Jesus Christ man Wow
Wow
Christy Christy Teegan was third up
three 13.5 million
what about Kylie Jenner she's she's not
a model she's not no no she's just just
makeup okay but she's like reality face
but this is that Kendall Kendall's like
part of the Victoria Secret Angels she's
like that I'm sure she said some work
done but she's not like all made up like
the other one yeah she's actually really
pretty always has been yeah high speed
Brody Jenner is a good-looking kid man
[ __ ] really Brody Jenner his son Bruce
Jenner's son you ever seen him oh yeah
really good looks small which is strange
he's absolutely not small he's every bit
of 6 2 and I've said I've stood next to
him he doesn't want to get into a bit of
also stood next to him and hung out with
him and went to do so I he's not small
he's far bigger than I am no way I've
spent time with him I promise look it up
see what his height is on here you can
see you next to his dad's very big he's
not some high heels on - yes dad six - I
mean Brody's a big kid he really is no I
just type in son I would not define him
as a big kid well tall I mean six - is
tall he's tall and I mean look at how
handsome he is do you get better look
six feet it says six feet and that's on
but he's not here oh so oh so first of
all they say six foot and that's usually
lying I'm just telling you I've stood
next to the guy he is said to be but
he's he's not a big kid you not was that
big you not classify him as but he's all
four so I'm not a big guy but he's
definitely bigger than I am so I went
through and and I have shoulders four
days and when the internet says you're
six foot that's a no you're not six foot
I don't know I mean I you know I don't I
didn't take a measuring stick out but I
was on my knees actually when I was
talking yeah no he's not a big uh well
I'm how we got certain Oh Kendall she's
killing it
she's killing it god I guess so right
she's number one model in the world well
you found her David Cassidy
Brian I worked with David Cassidy okay
well he passed away you were on a show
called cover me you know he died that he
created I know what happened was it just
drugs no loafer disease so most likely
tonight alcohol if it's liver yeah I
don't know sometimes people just have
dementia - I didn't know who he was he
was huge he was in he was in a group
called the partnership area and they
were the sort of original timer
cartridge really it had a TV show and
they were on a team band and they were
huge
and there were actually legit musicians
bring up the Partridge Family and he was
a real like teen idol you know people
loved him old school huh yeah look at
him real cutie maybe there you go I'm
sorry season one it was a huge show this
is them sing it
this in a sixty or 70s 60s
well I remember this
Danny Bonaduce
goddamn
you used to watch this way yep
it's a long man this is remember when
there are four networks and they were
like you know five shows there before
the Brady Bunch
I don't remember same type of I saw the
Brady Bunch so they have to be in before
the Brady Bunch right don't get a lot of
those family shows anymore the only
family show I can think of his family
guy yeah if there's not a lot like now
and that back then it was like there's
blackish
well Goldberg's family show
yeah Kohlberg there's a bunch of family
show things yeah the coal burns not
[ __ ] killing it there's Goldberg's
there's blackish there's I'm your name a
family all the ABC NBC CBS all family
[ __ ] yeah that kid from the Goldbergs
with that wears glasses like the star
yeah he's so freakin good I saw him on a
talk show once he's Fanta
it's like his person I was almost
exactly the same as on the show Sean is
a great lady
now he's [ __ ] man I've known him since
he's 14 he's now 17 on going on 18 it
might be 18 he's 18 it's kind of crazy
to watch these kids grow up it's kind of
interesting but he's great but they're
gonna say 20 yourself know he's always
been a great he's always hid total kid
yeah still total kid total kid and so
sweet and so he's just just a [ __ ]
nice guy man wrong one what's very
strong I've always found that child
actors and I've worked with a number of
them are very very intelligent kids
today castrated yeah disciplined
discipline danced and straight-a
students and just wise beyond their
years he's a good kid man look at that
he's so cute when he was little
Jesus and now he's an adult almost it's
ridiculous
well he's such a good guy they're the
old old casting sure is awesome he's
like his character right oh my god yeah
yeah it's a trip loves to laugh I'd love
to make him laugh in between tags he's
just just good kid good kid
your kids may am good kid let me leave
you with a little drop in knowledge here
please do I just want you guys to be
aware that there is a movement out there
I mean Joe Rogan were texting about it
yesterday and that moment is the idea
that certain ideas and opinions are
dangerous and certain ideas and opinions
are not safe to express and certain
ideas and opinions are are to be kept
sort of in to yourself and this is a how
do you not bring up Steve Martin I don't
know
speaking of Brian's dropping oh yeah
what happened god dammit it's a comedy
show Steve Martin you know his Egyptian
thing
yeah it's racist there you go there you
go
students blast Steve Martin's King Tut's
and how do you not bring that up let's
call them the illiberal left because the
illiberal left that there's a site
there's a there's a personal left wing
and it lives on academic campuses it
lives in the media it lives in even some
of the tech industry they are humorless
there is ZERO room for interpretation
and there is an orthodoxy of thought and
that orthodoxy of thought has to
encompass equality at all costs there's
something called equality of opportunity
and then there's something called we
have to have equality of outcome which
is another another form of Marxism I
think it's very very dangerous and you
are seeing on campuses where teachers
are being called in and being
reprimanded for even showing an
alternative point of view to something
and they're being censored because they
are neutral about it when they in fact
need to be against it or there's a
movement to get certain speech
classified as hate speech like it is in
Canada and believe me they're trying to
bring it to our country as well so that
certain things would be considered hate
speech even presenting an alternative
point of view like someone like Steve
Ben and Jordan Peterson is brilliant and
these people who have a different point
of view on things and this is a very is
a growing movement so please please be
aware play that King don't be afraid of
ideas put play that King help from
poking around they're saying it's not
seriously just for a moment one of the
great art exhibits ever to tour the
United States is the treasures of
Tutankhamen or King Tut but I think it's
a national disgrace the way we have
commercialized it with trinkets and toys
t-shirts and posters about three months
ago I was up in the woods and I wrote a
song I tried to use the ancient
modalities and melodies we'd like to do
it for you right now
maybe we can all learn yeah and this is
so offensive to Egyptians Egyptians who
have nothing to do with this
it wasn't even Arabic back then they're
sayings accents racist they're
ridiculous it's culturally insensitive
but they're so stupid they have no idea
what what this was back then it wasn't
Arabic it had nothing to do with the
current Egyptian culture the Egyptians
didn't speak Arabic
people are meted that nor were they
Muslim back then you know walk like an
Egyptian people had an outcry about that
too what's that
that song walk like an Egyptian people
were pissed off about that log off it
was ancient Egypt a completely different
culture had nothing to do with the
current culture nothing zero to do with
it but they're two so long to know that
it's long I'm sure this was in 1977 1977
I think but apparently this is too much
Jesus Christ man what is wrong with
people
well it's becoming tyrannical they're
saying this shone white supremacy at its
finest
now there you go Joe said the left eats
it's on the Left eats its own they're
there so they're there their scholarship
is laughable and they are making a
mockery of education these kids are not
educated they don't come out educated
they come out indoctrinated there's a
huge difference
no this there's a huge them being
indoctrinated an educated educated is
being exposed to all different ideas and
learning how to think critically and
learning how to get closer to the truth
not so in this we're also attacking
these old classic its culture yeah it
goes on around dude watch there's such
bigger problems that guy should be
putting out table to focus your energy
on this i'm telling but they are they're
gonna take muscle all white guys are not
the enemy it's crazy I know and by the
way Western culture I would like to add
Western culture again Reid sapiens
Western culture gave us concepts like
liberalism self-determination like I
don't know by the government by the
people of the people for the people it
gave us our Constitution which gave us
our longest-standing democracy it gave
us the concept of feminism the concept
of racism the cod leave these are
concepts that came out of the liberal
thinking's
of the universities and the liberal
minds of yes dead white men so you know
a little credit to where it's due it has
nothing to it being white or black or
anything else but but but Western
culture has something to offer it's not
all racist and imperialistic and if you
think it's imperialistic it might be
be colonial istic yes so has every group
so were the Persians so were the
Ottomans the Turks so were the
Babylonians so with the Assyrians we are
all a product of Empire we are all a
product of this you know all of us so
the idea that you can't escape that
there's no such thing as a pure culture
and they're just stupid and they're not
students of history read the book
sapiens it's a fantastic book that takes
all of this into account educate
yourself
arm yourself an education read widely
and broadly be responsive to the
evidence please boom
don't be an idiot all don't choose a
[ __ ] side and think you have the
truth I'm done and by the way if you
really want to see it if you really want
to see some [ __ ] come see me if you want
to laugh even more than you just did
yeah
come to wise guys Salt Lake City
starting Friday Saturday let's rock and
roll
we should talk about some more stuff I
think I think BSU get a flight oh crap
yeah I gotta get a flight my dad with
them well Turkey yeah um but I'm done
you know wise guys this weekend brother
I'm excited buddy Friday Saturday new
people fired up to come I don't know
what I mean I don't know what Oh Duke
you think King Tut was offensive wait
see Brian's blackface this salt lake
salt lake
turkey day Happy Thanksgiving everybody
yes happy to that Trinity enjoy that
stuff I'm in Ontario improv November
30th and then on the 16th through the
18th I'm in Buffalo helium and on the
15th we just add Syracuse one-night-only
Syracuse December 15th I love it and
then this is just giving an ounce I'm
sure by the times comes out tickets will
be on sale the night before UFC 220 in
Boston that Friday night I am doing the
Wilbert theater in Boston January 19th
right for the huge UFC in Boston
UFC 220 the night before I will be there
Wilbur theater tickets will be on sale
very soon if they're not up today
fantastic your tickets at T fat K
dot-com um Chris it's a finally kid
we're out